قال وزير الماليه والخزانه التركيه الجديد
محمد شيمشيك انخفض التضخم والشفافيه
والقدره على التنبؤ والامتثال للمعايير
الدوليه ستكون من ابرز المبادئ الاساسيه
التي ستعتمد عليها الوزاره لتحقيق الرفايع
المجتمعي واضاف الوزير انه سيقود العمل
بالتنسيق مع جميع الوزارات المعنيه وفقا
لهذه المعايير
سنبدا برنامجنا متوسطه مدى دون حيث سيكون
هدفنا الاساسي ارساء الانضباط المالي
وضمان استقرار الاسعار لتحقيق نمو مرتفع
المستدام وخفض معدل التضخم مجددا لخانه
واحده على المدى المتوسط وزياده القدره
على التنبؤ في جميع المجالات وتسريع
التحول الهيكلي الذي سيقلل عجز الميزان
التجاري هذه امور مهمه جدا لبلادنا وستكون
سياستنا الرئيسيه معتمده على دعم مصرفنا
المركزي في مكافحه التضخم عبر السياسات
الماليه وتنفيذ اصلاحات هيكليه هدفنا
الاساسي في المرحله المقبله رفع مستوى
الرفاه المجتمعي وستكون شفافيه والتنسيق
والانتثار للمعايير الدوليه مبادئنا
الاساسيه لتحقيق